abduction enlèvement d'êtres humains par
des extraterrestres area51 base
militaire secrète située dans le nevada
on y conduirait des études sur le
matériel technologique et biologiques
extraterrestre blue book project program
d'investigation de l'aéronautique
militaire des états unis d'amérique
lancé en 1952 dans le but de trouver une
explication scientifique sur les
observations d'ovnis fortement suspectés
de dépistage et d'étouffement cover un
complot du silence
stratégie prise d'un commun accord par
les puissances mondiales consistant à
enterrer toute preuve sur l'existence
des ovnis des boecklin discrédit
systématique des témoignages et des
témoins d'apparitions d'ovnis ainsi que
des organisations ufologiques et de
leurs chercheurs et b entités
biologiques extraterrestre exogamie
rapport sexuel entre un extraterrestre
est un humain
flamme nombre élevé d'observation dans
une zone déterminée à un moment donné ir
rencontres rapprochées avec les
extraterrestres majestic 12 groupes
secrets américains opérant à l'insu du
congrès et des institutions officielles
me ben men in black agents appartenant à
des organisations secrètes
il interviendrait régulièrement après
chaque rencontre rapprochée détruisant
les preuves et intimidant les témoins
ufo crash accident d'un ou de plusieurs
ovni pouvant être dus à des causes
différentes crash and erreur de
navigation
jusqu'au début du 16ème siècle la
conception ptolémaïque ou géométriques
prédominait on pensait que la terre
était au centre de l'univers
ce qui coïncidait entre autres avec
l'image biblique de l'homme
plus tard ce concept fut remplacé par le
système héliocentrique de copernic
selon lequel le soleil est au centre de
l'univers et la terre ainsi que tous les
autres corps lui tourner autour
on pense maintenant que le soleil de la
terre et les autres corps du système
solaire sont situés dans une région
quelconque de l'univers immense et c'est
pour cette raison que de nombreux
chercheurs imaginent que d'autres formes
de vie peuvent exister
les premiers noyaux atomiques ont dû se
former trois minutes après la naissance
de l'univers et les premiers atomes un
million d'années plus tard c'est ainsi
qu'a commencé une nouvelle phase pour
l'univers la lumière puisse se diffuser
dans toutes les directions et la matière
s'agréger sous l'effet de la gravité
formant les premiers corps célestes
d'aspe stalair les quasars
concernant notre système solaire il y a
environ 5 milliards d'années dans un
petit angle de l'univers à l'intérieur
de la voie lactée se produisit un
événement tout à fait normal pour la vie
du cosmos mais extraordinaire pour notre
ville
l'explosion d'une supernova une étoile
sur le point de mourir engendra une
série de phénomènes qui conduisirent à
la naissance de notre système solaire
le soleil les neuf planètes qui lui
tournent autour
les satellites et les astéroïdes
il est presque certain que des
phénomènes de ce genre se sont produits
et se produiront encore dans d'autres
points de l'univers suscitant de grands
espoirs pour la naissance d'autres
formes de vie qui selon les hypothèses
avancées par les chercheurs existait
déjà dans un passé lointain où
pourraient exister dans le futur
venus par exemple est une planète n'est
dans les conditions semblables à celles
de la terre pour ses dimensions sa
composition et sa distance par rapport
au soleil elle est aujourd'hui bien
différente de notre planète et nous
voulons espérer qu'elle ne représente
pas l'image de la terre dans le futur
l'imi à 2 milliards d'années environ
la luminosité du soleil était de 30%
inférieure à celle d'aujourd'hui
et cela laisse penser que des océans
pouvait jadis exister sur vénus les
océans ayant disparu l'anhydride
carbonique s'est accumulé dans
l'atmosphère provoquant les faits serre
qui a rendu la vie impossible
l'effet serre est un phénomène où
l'énergie émise par la surface de la
planète pour équilibrer l'énergie du
soleil en direction de l'espace est
partiellement absorbée par l'atmosphère
qui la renvoie à son tour vers la
planète sous forme de rayonnement
c'est pareil au 1
l'auteur
mars est une autre planète à prendre en
considération le succès de la mission de
la sonde qui en 1989 a lâché sur mars un
petit robot explorateur a exclu qu'il
pouvait exister des êtres humains sur
cette planète mais elle a également
confirmé que dans le passé mars devait
avoir des étendues d'eau un climat plus
chaud et peut-être quelques formes de
vie primordial cette possibilité dépend
tout dépendra de la température de la
surface qui est maintenant inférieure à
celle de la terre il est toutefois
possible que la température de mars
augmentent dans le futur
l'une des causes principales pourrait
être d'ici des dizaines de milliers
d'années
le déplacement de l'inclinaison de l'axé
de l'orbité de mars qui dépend de la
force de gravité du soleil et des autres
planètes
ceux-ci modifierait la quantité de
lumière solaire et par conséquent le
climat en effet on prévoit que la
luminosité du soleil augmente de 1% tous
les 100 millions d'années
ainsi dans quelques milliards d'années
comme cela c'est certainement produit
dans le passé les glaciers de mars
fonderont des océans se formeront et
cela favorisera peut être la naissance
et l'évolution de la vie mais ces
conditions favorables pour mars seront
désastreuses pour la terre toujours à
cause du rayonnement solaire
nos mères s'évaporeront et la planète
deviendra incandescente comme l'est
aujourd'hui venus
dans cet espace constitué de millions
d'étoilés et de galaxies se peut-il que
d'autres personnes pensent la même chose
que nous la vie est-elle un phénomène
exclusive de la terre s'il existait une
autre forme de vie aux confins de
l'univers serait elle semblable à un
autre on essaie depuis longtemps de
répondre à toutes ces questions
en tentant de capter des signaux radio
provenant des étoiles la nasa s'en
occupe elle aussi activement à tel point
qu'elle a décidé de préparer un
programme de recherche
le programme a été de nommer city
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
et il a été réalisé en collaboration
avec certains des plus grands chercheurs
dans le domaine de l'astronomie la bio
chimie la biologie l'astrophysique
l'anthropologie appartenons plus
prestigieuses universités américaines
le comportement de la plupart des
scientifiques consiste à dire que
puisqu'il existe des lois générale
valide dans tous les points de l'univers
ou presque
on peut penser qu'un certain phénomène
engendré dans un point peut très bien se
produire dans un autre l'idée consiste à
utiliser les radiotélescopes pendant une
période de quatre ou cinq ans en
écoutant l'espace et en cherchant les
différentes ondes radio qui nous arrive
du cosmos pour capter tout signal
anormal mais le projet seti n'inclut pas
que les radiotélescopes la recherche
continue également avec des sondes
spatiales toujours plus sophistiqués
naturellement on espère que d'autres
dans l'espace sont à l'écouté et
commence à recevoir nos signaux
nous aussi terrestres nous envoyons
involontairement depuis plus de 40 ans
une énorme quantité de signaux radio et
de télévision dans le cosmos depuis que
la télévision a été inventé et bien
avoir encore avec les ondes radio même
si elles sont moins puissants ces
signaux peuvent nous permettre d'être
capté mais également les radios phare
qui envoie intentionnellement des
messages codés à très grande distance
des informations concernant des faits
mystérieux ou du moins étrange arrivent
du monde entier des phénomènes
inexplicables des traces d'ovni la
première chose étrange que les
chercheurs étudient depuis des années
sont les constructions antiques tels que
les colonnes de pierre de stonehenge le
monument mégalithique de stonehenge et
est utilisé dans l'antiquité pour
trouver le solstice d'été et d'hiver
un observateur placé au centre du cercle
principal des pierres de stonehenge
voyez le soleil se lever durant le
solstice d'été à travers un couloir
précis qui continue hors du cercle
l'aube et le coucher du soleil du
solstice d'hiver étaient encadrés par
d'autres pierres placées à l'intérieur
du cercle le fait étrange est que ce
monument a été réalisée d'une manière
tellement parfaite que l'on pourrait
penser que d'autres civilisations plus
développés peut-être extraterrestres ont
participé à sa construction
d'étranges de sensations exotérique se
ressentent entre les pyramides de
teotihuacan au mexique devient une
tradition font penser grâce à leur
rythme à la visite possible
d'extraterrestres les gens croient en
leur tour cette sensation se retrouve
également dans les régions péruvienne où
la légende de inco et chats le fils du
soleil continue à se transmettre de
génération en génération
à cette époque souverain était à la tête
de la religion un homme demande à son
présumé dieu que faites vous ici et
l'autre répond je suis là pour vous
étudiez cette civilisation florissante
s'éteignit soudainement pour des motifs
que l'on ignore
mais les anciens un cas qui provenaient
des étoiles avait promis de retourner
sur la terre au pérou des signes
étranges se développe sur des kilomètres
s'agit-il des pistes d'atterrissage pour
les véhicules extraterrestre la visite
de ces étrangers représentent l our
présentera-t-elle un jour un risque pour
la terre
qui sont les chercheurs doivent n'est
que font-ils
que cherche-t-il les militaires se
mobilisent les scientifiques
s'intéressent à eux les techniciens
archives adresse sur photographies et
films tous recherchent des preuves on
trace des portraits robots de ces objets
volants les ovnis les facultés sont
construites pour étudier les phénomènes
entrant dans l'atmosphère
elles sont chargées de classer tous les
cas d'observation
documents sur l'accident d'un disque
volant sur une tentative de contact avec
un terrestre sur un enlèvement par des
extraterrestres ces événements
extraordinaires contribuèrent à diminuer
momentanément la tension existant entre
l'amérique et la russie
même s'il était déjà en guerre froide
les soviétiques suspectait qu'il se
passait quelque chose d'anormal
il accusait les américains de les
espionner avec des machines secrets et
les américains pensaient exactement le
contraire
en effet les américains avaient réussi à
construire une soucoupe volante qui leur
avait coûté plusieurs milliards de
dollars
une véritable merveille de la physique
mais qui ne fut pas capable de voler à
plus de deux mètres autour du
laboratoire secret
dans les années 70 lorsque les
observations de vienne de notoriété
publique les témoignages apparaissent se
multiplient dans toute la planète et il
s'agit souvent de témoin crédible et
compétent comme par exemple des pilotes
et l'équipage d'avions de ligne le 14
avril 1977
la tour de contrôle informe le capitaine
de la suisse air que quelque chose le
suit l'affairé rapidement archives et
1980 le pilote d'un avion de chasse
finlandais pourchasse un ovni mais à
quoi ressemblaient les objets volants à
quelle distance se trouvait-il le pilote
répond toujours de la même façon
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait ressenti une
forte sensation de chaleur et que le
radar de bord était devenu fou
en tentant de suivre les deux lumière
blanchâtre qui appartenait sans aucun
doute à des corps solide
1997 ukraine un amateur à l'occasion de
filmer l'une des observations les plus
importantes qui est officiellement
classé observations d'ovni objet volant
non identifié 10 septembre 1997
peu avant 22 heures durant une fête
d'anniversaire une caméra vidéo filmé
une traînée qui semble s'écraser sur les
apennins de passe on passe alors un
accident d'avion et l'on organise des
opérations de sauvetage à grande échelle
elles se termineront l'après midi du
jour suivant sans résultat ce film
exceptionnel a été réalisé par un
amateur dans la ville de joie et son
maxi les séquences furent tout d'abord
saisi par les autorités
ce n'est qu'aujourd'hui seulement qu'un
groupe de journalistes a réussi à les
récupérer et les ont rendues publiques
un cas d'observation collective habile
easy en géorgie durant un concert
il
juillet 1999 un journaliste recueille le
témoignage d'un agriculteur habitant à
boudriot italie qui a photographié en
pleine campagne
un objet volant de forme ovale qui se
déplaçait à une vitesse constante au
dessus des champs cultivés à
l'improviste l'objet lumineux s'est mis
à accélérer vers le ciel en 1979
l'académie des sciences américaine avait
publié un dossier officiel sur les ovnis
après avoir enquêté sur 250 cas
d'observation considérés comme les plus
mystérieux mais aussi les plus crédibles
puisque les témoins étaient des pilotes
militaires et des astronautes dans la
plupart des cas analysés
le rapport se concluait par inexplicable
des ovnis n'ont jamais été une nouveauté
dans l'histoire de l'homme
toutefois selon les enquêteurs même si
de nombreuses personnalités éminentes du
monde scientifique et politique sont
convaincus de leur existence
à ce jour aucune preuve convaincante n'a
été présentée à ce sujet
les témoignages paraît-il peuvent être
le fruit de l'imagination
les photographies et les fines peuvent
être faux ou représentés simplement
d'étranges événements astronomiques
météorologiques
même si souvent les événements invoquées
sont tout aussi étrange et insolite que
ce que l'on essaie d'expliquer mais que
se passerait-il si l'un de ces ovnis
imaginaire s'écrasait au sol dans un
lieu pouvant être rejoints par les
forces aériennes et terrestres d'un pays
civilisé
comment se comporterait le gouvernement
de ce pays
préparerait-il un communiqué de presse
pour informer le monde entier ou et
serait-t-il au contraire d'étouffer la
sphère en tamponnant les fuites et 1
obligeant les témoins éventuels à se
taire à l'improviste
j'ai remarqué dans le ciel des faisceaux
lumineux il se déplaçait rapidement avec
des mouvements harmonieux géométrie
malheureusement quelques minutes plus
tard il avait disparu
l'autre soir pendant que j'observais le
ciel j'ai aperçu un objet lumineux même
avec le télescope je n'ai pas réussi à
suivre
oui de temps en temps on aperçoit des
choses étranges dans le ciel je ne sais
pas ce que c'est mais nous les voyons
demain
m
je
mais quel carburant pourrait utiliser
les véhicules extraterrestres pour
effectuer des voyages interstellaires le
magnétisme hydrodynamique pourrait
générer le type de propulsion utilisée
par les véhicules spatiaux les
expériences effectuées dans les
laboratoires du snr s démontre que la
poussée produite sur un objet ayant des
géométries aérodynamique particulière
pour lui faire dépasser le mur du son
tout en maintenant une vitesse constante
sans émettre le classique bang ni subir
de dommage ce qui expliquerait le
silence des ovnis
une autre expérience montre que la
propulsion ionisent l'air environnant
produisant des rayons infrarouges et
ultraviolets
bien que l'augmentation des observations
commence à convaincre les astronomes de
la véracité des preuves la forte
incrédibilité et faust est maintenue par
les responsables se transforme encore en
persécutions contre les témoins de faits
céleste
il est pourtant vrai qu'il est possible
de se tromper de nombreux objets peuvent
donner lieu à des équivoques
avant tout il y a naturellement les
avions et les hélicoptères
il peut quelquefois s'agir d'exercice
nocturne il peut s'agir également de
débris de satellite ou des réservoirs
qui en entrant dans l'atmosphère
s'enflamme comme des météores
cela peut être des météorites des
phénomènes électriques dans nos sphères
comme les ondes hydro magnétique qui
reproduit en laboratoire ressemble
vraiment à une formation de soucoupe
volante
mais il existe également de nombreuses
photos qui représentent des objets
extraordinaires en forme de disque de
cigares de caunes et semble réellement
être des ovnis
au cours d'une enquête récente un
journaliste scientifique américain a
étudié à fond plusieurs piché de photos
prises au cours de ces dernières années
et a déclaré qu'aucune de ces photos
nettes est authentique et pourtant ces
clichés avaient été analysés dans des
laboratoires spécialisés et déclaré
authentique
il existe en faveur de la théorie des
visites d'extraterrestres un grand
nombre de vidéos tournées par des
amateurs
il a été récemment possible d'en
visualiser quelques unes qui aurait été
censuré par les autorités ou ce set au
service et pourrait observer le prêt tôt
et mexico et ce film a été tourné dans
le zoo de la ville de sydney il est
particulièrement intéressant car il
présente non seulement l'ovni mais
également plusieurs points de repères
avec la terre dans les premiers photo g
nous apercevons une personne qui pointe
le doigt dans la direction de l'objet ce
qui confirme que d'autres personnes ont
également remarqué ce phénomène ce film
est particulièrement intéressant car il
présente non seulement l'ovni mais
également plusieurs points de repères
avec la terre telle que les
constructions du zoo et l'arbre derrière
lequel on distingue clairement à la fin
du film l'objet et son halo rougeâtre
due à l'énergie électromagnétique qui le
déplace
de nombreuses hypothèses existent sur le
phénomène ovni
la plus connue est sans aucun doute
celle des extraterrestres selon laquelle
les objets volants non identifiés
seraient désastreux neige provenant
d'autres mondes
la possibilité d'une vie intelligente au
delà de notre planète est un problème
qui occupe et divise depuis toujours les
scientifiques et fascine les gens
l'éventualité que d'autres créatures
visite déjà notre planète a contribué à
développer l'intérêt et la curiosité
vis-à-vis du phénomène ovni les rapports
officiels des autorités continuent à
affirmer qu'il n'existe aucune preuve en
mesure de confirmer de manière
irréfutable
toutes les thèses sur les visiteurs de
l'espace et que la réalité ne peut pas
leur fournir de réponse sur la forme des
astronef des soucoupes volantes ou des
cigares volant et sur la présence
d'extraterrestres de petite taille et à
la peau verte
parallèlement à l'hypothèse
extraterrestre d'autres thèses plus
exotiques se sont développés concernant
les voyageurs dans le temps les univers
parallèles les apparitions religieuse
ces théories sont divulguées pour
pousser les gens vers des situations que
l'on pourrait définir irrationnel mais
qui rentre évidemment dans le domaine de
l'imagination et de la spéculation
scientifique
une autre hypothèse politique ni au
contraire toutes causes extraordinaire
et déclare qu'il s'agirait de véhicules
expérimentaux plus ou moins secrets de
phénomènes atmosphériques encore
inconnues ou d'une simple confusion de
la part des témoins sous l'effet du
mythe des ovnis ainsi les autorités ont
établi que à l'état actuel des
connaissances il n'existe aucune preuve
concrète en faveur de la théorie sur les
visiteurs et que les informations
recueillies sont insuffisantes pour
entamer une série d' enquête à cause de
leurs insuffisances et de leur
imprécision
le vrai problème lorsqu'on a affaire à
des événements concernant les
intelligence extraterrestre et qu'il
existe selon des témoins deux rencontres
rapprochées une très grande variété de
race l'homme étant le seul point de
départ permettant de mesurer toute chose
il est nécessaire d'avoir un nouveau
système de mesure
si quelqu'un est en train de visiter
notre planète
et si plus de 4 millions de personnes en
amérique est presque un million en
italie affirme avoir été enlevé
il serait intéressant de savoir non pas
sur quel type de véhicule et ont voyagé
mais surtout qui les a enlevés et
pourquoi
comment vit-on de l'autre côté du ciel
que mon style à quoi pense qu'yves
quelles sont leurs passe temps
quelles sont les choses importantes pour
eux en cataloguant les races
extraterrestres grâce aux témoignages de
rencontres rapprochées
nous arrivons la conclusion
philosophique que l'homo sapiens n'est
pas la dernière étape de notre évolution
en tant que race humaine
mais il semblerait que de belles
surprises nous attendent dans le futur
si nous arrivons à survivre à notre
destructivité
on
plusieurs entités extraterrestres sont
regroupés sous la définition de nordique
il est probable que dans le passé ces
êtres ont été pris pour des messagers
divins
certains d'entre eux habiterait encore
sur notre planète sous une identité
terrestre et serait pratiquement
identique à un suédois ou un norvégien
il existe plusieurs types d'être
nordique
le nordique classique il a la peau
claire lisse et sans défauts mais il
n'existe pas beaucoup d'informations sur
leur physiologie
il semble que leur capacité de
reproduction soit semblable aux humains
qu'ils soient compatibles avec notre
nourriture et qu'il réussisse à modifier
leur densité moléculaire par la pensée
le nordique humain il a les cheveux
blonds comme les blés et les yeux très
clairs il serait impossible de le
reconnaître si ce n'est grâce à un
examen médical détaillé
le nordique nazis ses mains ont six
doigts et il mesure 1 mètre 90 ces êtres
aurait quelques difficultés à se
reproduire
le nordique géant sa structure osseuse
et musculaire est beaucoup plus
développé que la normale il peut mesurer
jusqu'à 2 mètres et provenir d'une
planète dont la gravité est supérieure à
la nôtre
le nordique elfique il aurait une
certaine biocompatibilité avec les
humains et serait doté d'une grande
agilité
son visage est plus fin et plus écrasés
que la normale par l'effet sol et sa
peau très lisse à une couleur olivâtre
le nordique orange il a des cheveux des
yeux clairs souvent rouge brillant un
physiquement et frêle
la personnalité des nordiques varie
selon les groupes
mais ils sont caractérisés par un
comportement aimable disponibles
certainement dictée par une certaine
logique
même au cours d enlèvement les nordiques
le semble avoir une certaine capacité
d'interagir
ils essaient de calmer l'otage en
communiquant avec lui télépathiquement
quelquefois les nordiques semble
intéresser à un échange culturel avec
les humains ne connaissons peu de choses
sur les traditions culturelles des
nordiques
quand certains otages ou simplement les
personnes contactées leur ont demandé
quelques explications
les nordiques ont parlé d'un passé où il
avait failli s'autodétruire par un excès
de passion violente
après cette période il avait commencé à
reconstruire une société équilibrée
la technologie développée par les
nordiques et parmi les plus avancés
il possède deux petits astronef
d'exploration et de grands vaisseaux
réservé pour les longues exploration et
pour la défense de leur territoire
ils ont des dispositifs capables de
dissimuler les astronef mais aussi les
personnes des boucliers de protection et
des armes de différents types très
efficaces ils ont en outre développé une
science médicale plutôt efficace
la race des grilles possède de grands
pouvoirs mentaux et une prédisposition
pour la technologie
le gris orange a une tête en forme de
coeur et n'a pas de cheveux la peau des
hommes et doré et seins des femmes est
orange les hommes aux cinq doigts les
femmes 3 seulement ils possèdent de
grands pouvoirs télépathiques et même la
capacité de prendre l'aspect qui leur
plaît le plus d'après certaines
informations il semblerait qu'ils aient
la possibilité de se réincarner même
comme être humain
le gris vidéo sans tilly à une
physiologie général très semblable à
celle des humains
même s'il existe des différences
importantes des yeux foncés et une
pupille très large recouverte d'une
lentille foncé il possède six doigts par
membres ce qui fait penser à un fort
penchant pour la même qualité
le gris robuste par rapport aux autres
types de grille à une musculature forte
et tonique avec des protubérances à
proximité de certaines zones du corps du
peut-être à des jointures se veut
particulière sa peau est gris clair dur
et souvent il n'a pas de cheveux un
détail important il possède une
véritable dentition à la place de la
plaque gingivale qui caractérise les
autres grilles ils réussi à communiquer
oralement
car il possède aussi des cordes vocales
et une structures phonétiques semblable
à vingt autres
le gris marron a des yeux rouges et
grands allongé inclinés trois doigts par
membres une musculature mince mais très
résistante une pour vertueuse couleur
marron le gris élever sa musculature
hypotonique recevra encore plus par sa
hauteur il est toutefois assez lent dans
les mouvements
il semble posséder une sorte de sagesse
ancestrale et c'est certainement pour
cela qu'il a souvent un rôle de
commandement le gris blanc sa tête est
chauve certainement disproportionnée par
rapport à la structure de son corps
réellement minuscule qui est mystifié
par le fait qu'il se présente presque
toujours en groupe
il est en mesure de faire de grand saut
avec une légèreté incroyable
souvent ceux qui sont en contact avec
eux ont la sensation que des enfants les
emmène jouer mais il ne semble pas
possible de pouvoir interagir avec eux
le gris classique à des muscles
hypotonique tellement réduit qui
semblent adhérer aux hausses les yeux
généralement recouvert de lentilles
foncé sont grands et incliné et ils
enveloppent les côtés du crâne
tout cela leur donne un aspect
inquiétant le cerveau est très développé
et il possède de grands pouvoirs de
télépathie et de télékinésie
il semblerait en effet qu'il soit doté
de 4 loeb cérébraux mais les soucoupes
volantes et les extraterrestres
existe-t-il vraiment at on peur d'une
guerre ou d'une invasion ou ressentons
seulement le besoin de quelque chose de
magique pour s'opposer à la rationalité
quotidienne londres un urologue dénonce
dans un livre
le gouvernement a les preuves de
l'existence des extraterrestres toscane
observation d'un globe lumineux
pekin 4 venir observer et photographier
arizona un avion militaire disparaît
dans le vide
enlevé par les ovnis allemagne un ovni
fait la course avec une auto
les résultats des enquêtes sont toujours
top secret et toutes les apparitions
d'ovnis sont liquidés comme imagination
de déséquilibrer erreur d'évaluation
ballon-sonde nuages aux formes étranges
ou perturbation atmosphérique de type
horreur boréale la position officielle
vis-à-vis des soucoupes volantes et
toujours tellement sceptiques qu'elle
frôle le ridicule
toutefois les autorités ne peuvent pas
expliquer de nombreuses observations
espace dernière frontière
l'homme est allé est revenu de la lune
il a des sondes qui orbitent autour des
planètes
il scrute l'univers au delà de notre
galaxie pourquoi ne pas croire que cela
soit réversible et que d'autres
personnes ne font pas la même chose dans
des lieux différents
durant des symposiums sur l'univers il a
été possible de discuter avec de
nombreux scientifiques qui croient aux
extraterrestres mais aucun d'eux pas
même ceux qui préparent des projets pour
la recherche d'autres civilisations ne
croit aux ovnis peut-être parce qu'une
grande partie ne les ont pas étudié les
sceptiques sur cet argument répondent
que la communauté scientifique est prête
à accepter toutes choses nouvelles à
condition que l'on prouve son existence
nous avons souvent tendance à oublier
qu'il existe toujours des personnes qui
scrute professionnellement le ciel sans
interruption pas seulement les
astronomes
mais surtout les centres militaires des
coudes spatiale
aux usa par exemple il existe la
centrale souterraine de colorado springs
où est concentrée le système nerveux de
la défense aérienne américaine c'est ici
que sont centralisées toutes les
informations provenant du monde entier
24 heures sur 24 des radars dispersés
sur toute la planète et une série de
systèmes des coudes spatiale surveille
le ciel grâce au satellite et sont prêts
à signaler tout véhicule suspect
il semble donc étrange que pendant ces
trente dernières il eu plus de 70000
observation de la part de personne et
que personne de cette base ne rit jamais
rien vu on peut supposer que les ovnis
ont une technologie tellement avancé
qu'elle peut être imperceptible où il
faut admettre comme l'affirment de
nombreux collègues que les militaires
savent beaucoup de choses et qu'ils nous
les cache quoi qu'il en soit il semble
difficile que des objets restent secrets
alors que la cia les rend publiques
un autre mystère concernant le
gouvernement américain et la zone 51
zone dans laquelle se trouveraient des
pièces appartenant des objets non
identifiés
après cette brève recherche sur les
possibilités de vie au delà de notre
planète nous pouvons désormais donner
une conclusion la fascination qu'exerce
le mystère sur l'esprit humain a été une
raison pour développer la connaissance
du monde qui nous entoure
ainsi que la science moderne notre désir
incessant de résoudre les mystères de
l'espace nous a conduit à explorer le
système solaire les étoiles et les
planètes de notre système puis d'autres
univers
au cours de ces cinq cent dernières
années nous avons pratiquement terminée
l'exploration géographique du monde
chasseurs et or log ont respectivement
exterminer et cataloguer la plupart de
la vie animale terrestre
l'homme d'aujourd'hui et d'hier a été
étudiée est classé en détail
même les populations lointaines et non
civilisés nous sont devenues familières
grâce à la télévision qu' il y a trois
siècles à peine aurait été considérée
comme une magie
dans un monde de robes domicile voyage
dans l'espace ingénierie génétique et
des premiers pas vers la création d'une
vie artificielle on pourrait se demander
s'il reste encore d'autres mystères à
éclaircir
pourtant si nous considérons les dangers
de l'ère atomique et le développement de
la guerre sur des bases scientifiques
nous restera-t-il du temps pour
découvrir de nouveaux secrets de
l'univers avant que l'humanité soit
détruite
à l'heure actuelle on parle
régulièrement d'observations d'ovnis
surtout dans le triangle des bermudes
qui à cause d' anomalie magnétique et de
ces aberrations climatique soudaine a
été considérée par quelqu'un comme une
porte d'entrée cosmique
quoi qu'il en soit pour protéger ce que
nous avons et nous développer encore
plus il nous reste une arme puissante le
potentiel de l'esprit humain dont nous
n'utilisons qu'une partie infime
avec ou sans intelligence notre univers
poursuivra son évolution
la terre elle aussi se dirige avec toute
la galaxie dans une course cosmique qui
durera encore des milliards d'années et
qui se présente plein de mystères
à
planètes étoiles comme animaux et
plantes ne vivent pas éternellement mais
suivent la loi qui gouvernent toute
chose l'inesss ils accomplissent leur
cycle de vie
il meurt la terre subira elle aussi le
même sort à moins que nous ne fassions
sauter notre planète avant son temps
mais cela est un autre discours
avec l'évolution les choses vont et
viennent toujours plus comme par exemple
il y à 65 millions d'années lorsque se
produisit une extinction inexplicable
qui a entraîné la disparition des cars
de la vie de toute la planète y compris
tous les grands animaux
m
il existe encore tellement de choses que
nous ne connaissons pas et que nous
ignorons où que l'intelligence humaine
qui est donc limitée ne réussit pas à
comprendre
il est très difficile
une vie comme la nôtre existe mais tout
est possible
il serait peut-être plus probable que la
vie sur d'autres planètes existe mais
sous forme primordial mais cela n'est
pas sûr peut-être existe-t-il quelqu'un
sur une autre planète qui scrute en ce
moment le ciel dans notre direction
ou bien nous sommes inexorablement seule
dans un espace sans limite dans tous les
cas si nous regardons l'univers nous ne
pouvons que ressentir une sensation
immense d'être plus proche à notre terre
qui reste malgré tous ses défauts
un lieu merveilleux pour vivre
et loin des bactéries de l'univers nous
nous rendons compte à quel point notre
planète et douce avec sa nature ses
animaux ses paysages et ses peuples
si nous regardons plus loin dans
l'espace et le temps nous réussirons à
comprendre à quel point les choses qui
nous sont proches sont précieuses et
nous devrions apprendre à les aimer un
peu plus
mon
m